Your shah Aline Reis wants to know by chance.
With all due respect,
of course,
you're against the guys over there.
Look,
my position will always be what the word of God guides me,
right?
Because I live the word so we do not agree with the sin.
I think sin is somethingable and it distances people from God,
but I love people that my heart always goes for.
It is open to release love,
this source of love that is Jesus within my life is being released every day.
God created man and woman,
God in his fullness.
He thought about the structure of the family,
for society you will be a woman,
but for God you will always be the way you see the world.
Man is only homophobic.
Thunder.
Who told you has homosexual friends?
I tell them like this,
O boy.
God loves you,
you know?
I wanted to be you.
God just doesn't love what you do.
I'm not criticizing anyone,
I just can't agree with something that God doesn't agree with,
I have to speak the truth,
because the only thing that releases is the truth,
for if the son help you with us,
you will be free.
If that word built you up comment ame,
I believe.